You alone.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
the book of fasting
and this chapter now that we are going
to
delve into is regarding ing two types
of people that
were not explicitly
mentioned in the Quran
but they fall under the generalization
of the allowance given in the Quran.
Now, in order for us to understand the
rulings of Islam, we have to understand
something and that is that the rulings
of Islam are not arbitrary. They're not
random. They're not just general things
that are mentioned that don't fall into
a specific pattern.
All of the
laws of Islam, all of the rulings of
Islam,
they are all built on a common
foundation
and all of the subsequent rulings will
be branching off of that of that common
foundation.
This is how all of the rulings are
structured. So whenever we want to
research something, we want to learn
something, we want to learn a ruling, we
first start with the foundations
of that particular thing. Then we go off
into the branches
because without understanding the
foundation,
we will not be able to see the patterns
that the scholars of Islam see. And this
is what they base their rulings on. This
is where the rulings of the Quran and
Sunnah come from. They are all branching
off of a similar foundation.
When it comes to
the rulings of fasting,
we if we look at the way that the author
here has built his arguments, if we look
at the way that the author has
structured the book of fasting,
we see that first we began with upon
whom is fasting obligated, right? So we
take that that criteria
Then after that we look at who is
exempted from that obligation and if
they are exempted why are they exempted.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions
two exemptions in the Quran from
fasting. He says, "Subhan,"
he says, "And if you all are ill or
traveling,
then you are to make the days missed
during Ramadan up from the remainder of
the year from other days."
So we have two allowances here, two
exemptions,
travel and illness.
But we notice that
illness is a general term
that has other things that would be in a
person's life that aren't necessarily
illness per se. They may be natural.
They may be perfectly healthy but they
present the same circumstances as
illness.
If we understand this, we'll understand
the following chapters, the following
research that we will go into now.
So for instance
if we have
illness
we can say generally speaking with
respect to the duration of illness the
duration there are two types of illness.
Number one,
there is temporary illness, momentary
illness.
And number two, there is permanent or
there is
what we could say
illness that is around and does not have
a foreseeable cure.
The scholars refer to these two types of
illness as
meaning temporary. Musmin meaning that
it is indefinite. It's chronic.
It is long- winded illness. There's no
the the prognosis is very long with this
illness. Okay.
Now, what is the ruling for a person who
is ill with a temporary
illness or an illness that has a an
average def definite time, right? We
would say that
that person is as Allah instructed, they
will just make those days up when
they're better, right?
Now what about if a person has
musmin if they have something chronic,
something that is indefinite, something
that is
very lengthy illness that could stretch
years or
an illness which
cannot be or is not expected
for a person to be cured of. Then what
what do we do with this illness? What is
this person's
obligation?
This person's obligation
is
as Allah stipulates in the Quran.
Then notice the wording here.
that
the person is going to
pay the expeation,
the fya. And the fya is one
average meal for a po poor person
to feed one poor person a full meal. One
full meal.
Okay.
Now when we look at those two things we
say okay what is the reason that this
and this are different?
Well, the reason obviously is the
duration, right? One has a definite
duration, an approximate duration,
whether it's a month or two or five,
it's within a year, and the other does
not. The other is chronic. The other is
indefinite. The other is not expected to
ever resolve itself.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made it that the person who is expecting
to be cured or well enough to fast that
they are merely to fast a day in its
place and a person who is not expecting
to be cured that this person is to feed
one poor person a full meal.
Now
when we look at other circumstances a
person may have in his life that would
present themselves,
they may not be illness per se, but they
run in the same vein as illness,
right?
for instance, we mentioned
ministration.
A woman cannot
fast when she is on her menstrual
cycle.
This is not illness. As a matter of
fact, this is the image of health.
However, it runs in the same vein as
illness.
Therefore, it takes the same ruling.
But which type of those
two rulings does it take? Does it take
the ruling of the temporary illness or
the permanent illness? Temporary was
only a week or two or a month at most,
right?
whatever it is. So it is temporary.
It's within a year.
Therefore, if circumstances present
themselves
that are similar to these two,
they're not it's not an illness, but it
runs in the same vein.
Then we are going to look at the
duration.
Is it going to be temporary to where it
is more similar
to
temporary illness? Therefore, they are
to have the recourse of the temporarily
ill or is it more similar to permanent
illness, chronic illness to which a
person will take the recourse of the
chronically ill.
So when it comes to menration or
postpartum, we say temporary. So what
does a woman on her postpartum or
menstrual cycle do? She merely makes up
the days that she misses. This is what
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
commanded.
Now
let's say
another issue comes up that presents
itself for a woman
such as breastfeeding.
Breastfeeding. How long is breastfeeding
mentioned in the Quran to be two years?
This is
two full years. We said if it goes
beyond a year,
it is now falling into the realm of
chronic.
Now breastfeeding is not an illness but
it presents the same set of
circumstances that illness does.
Therefore it gives the same allowance
that illness does.
And so a person may say well what is the
recourse for a woman who is
breastfeeding?
We say well we have to look at the
situation.
Is she going to be breastfeeding
for two years? Is she only breastfeeding
for five months? Is she going to be done
breastfeeding within a year to where she
can make those days up or is it going to
go beyond a year? If the answer is it's
going to go beyond a year, then which
type of illness recourse do we take
here?
Musman, the the the permanent, the
chronic. So her experation is what? to
feed one poor person for every day that
she misses.
However, let's say
that it is less than a year. Then her
recourse is what? Her recourse is to
make up those days.
Let's say that she is pregnant.
Pregnancy is only going to be how long
at most?
N months. beyond that something's going
on, right? So
9 months if we added in the worst case
scenario the postpartum in there of 40
days, we still have time to make up the
days missed of Ramadan or not. Yes. So
which recourse would she take? The
temporary. But now let's say she
is going to give birth and then she's
going to breastfeed.
Well then now what does she do? Well now
she follows the recourse of the chronic
illness. It's not illness but it runs in
the same vein because it presents the
same set of circumstances.
This is the fatwa of Abu Jabbd
Omar and others of the companions.
There's no set recourse for a woman who
is breastfeeding or a woman who is
pregnant because it depends on the
circumstances.
if it will resolve itself. If we say if
she is able to make up the days that she
misses before the next Ramadan,
then she makes the days up. If not, then
she is to what? Pay the fya or to feed
the poor person. But you let's say a
woman gets into a situation where she is
where she is
giving birth
and then breastfeeding and then giving
birth and then breastfeeding and then
giving birth and then breastfeeding. How
long is the longest
type of punishment
or expeation of fasting?
The longest the most a person would ever
ever ever fast in the legislation of
Islam.
83 days. That's a very specific number.
How long is the
huh? 60 for what?
For instance, right?
Accidental or what we would call in in
Western law manslaughter, right? Or
accidentally
killing a Muslim.
The most a person would fast is how
long? 60 days.
There's even taking a life isn't beyond
60 days. So a woman comes and says, "I
have 10 Ramadans to make up." We say,
"Go ahead and fast for 10 months."
This is not an act of worship anymore.
This now is punishment,
right?
This this takes it out of the spirit of
what fasting is legislated for. Remember
the basis of all of the rulings of
fasting all go back to one main ruling
and that is
Allah desires ease for you and he does
not desire difficulty.
So anything that takes us into the realm
of difficulty,
we know it is not part of the essential
legislation of fasting. Correct? Because
Allah mentions in the Quran the rulings
of fasting and then he anchors it all in
this statement. Allah desires ease for
you. Does not desire difficulty for you.
Right?
So when we have a situation where a
woman now needs to have a three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, 10 years
of Ramadan to make up. No, that's why we
say anything beyond
one year. This now goes into the realm
of difficulty. Is it not? So is there
any situation where a person is
commanded to fast more than 30 days per
year obligatory?
The pillars of Islam are 30 days at the
most a person would ever fast a year.
Anything beyond that
we know that it is what
it is incorrect. So therefore when the
companions
they understood this balance they
understood the circumstances.
Therefore
when it comes to a woman who is
breastfeeding or a woman who is pregnant
they have the same ruling. Both have an
allowance to break their fast. Even if
fasting is easy for them, even if it's
not difficult, even if they are not
finding it, they're not fearing for
their children, they can break their
fast just a person traveling and
just a person who was ill. They
have an allowance. Doesn't matter if
it's hard or easy. That's not the
determining factor here. And so the same
goes for a woman who is pregnant or
breastfeeding as we will hear inshallah
in the evidences that the author cites.
Therefore she may break her fast. When
she breaks her fast what now is the
obligation upon her? It is depending on
how much of the fasting she's going to
miss. The men have to pay more attention
to this class than any woman does. Why?
Because who is responsible for your
women?
Huh? We are. You know, when our women
fall short, you know who's held
accountable for that? We are.
Our women now, right now,
are expected to be men and women at the
same time.
You know why? Cuz we dropped the ball.
That's why,
right?
That's on us.
And so when a man's wife or daughter or
sister or mother makes a mistake,
the male, her guardian will always have
will always have a part to play in that.
Always.
Even if it is your slave girl,
she still has those rights upon you.
Because a woman is not a man. A
woman if if if a man if if the human
being in general is weak,
if a man is weak, how much more so will
this be for the female?
And this is why
the man, the male masculinity, it is an
additional
portion
over femininity as Allah tells us in the
Quran. And this is why when a person
receives the blessing of a son, he
slaughters how much how many
you know how many for a son? Two. And
for a daughter, one. Is that because
he's not grateful for his daughter? No,
he's grateful. He slaughtered one. But a
son is more useful. He has an additional
portion of thanks to be given. However,
that additional blessing comes with
responsibility.
Responsibility.
It's not just responsibility
which is mentioned to us in the
western culture. Now, the man is the guy
that just carries the groceries and yes,
darling, and takes out the trash and
makes the money and you know that's
that's his job, right? Otherwise, just
be quiet. That's that's not what a man
is. That's a very topical superficial
view of what a man is. A man is much
more than that. is a leader, a
protector,
a an authority, right? Authority comes
with responsibility.
And so the point here is that a lot of
times when I discuss, you know, in my
experience in teaching
rulings on fasting or ministration or,
you know, I've taught this book for 20
years probably and when we get to the
chapters on menration, the chapters on
postpartum, the chapters on pregnancy,
the chapters on I see the students eyes
glaze over what does does this have
to do with me? Oh, it has a lot to do
with you. Right? Because weakness in our
women is a reflection of
our weakness and strength in women is a
reflection of
our strength.
when in the time of the companions
if a man would run from battle
and make his way back to Medina,
right? He ran away, snuck back into
town. The women in town would stone him
out of the town. What are you doing
here?
They would stone him out of the town.
It's better for him to be on the
battlefield than to go home in shame.
Where did that strength come from? It
came from the companions.
They didn't raise their sons and their
men to be my whole life is just my wife
and that's the that's all I want in my
life and nothing else. I was only
created to just, you know, rub my wife's
feet and and and that's the that's the
ceiling of my ambition. Nor were the
daughters of the companions raised to
see that in a man.
That was viewed as weakness.
I came back to be with you. I couldn't
be away from you too long.
Right? I ran away from battle because I
couldn't stay away from you another day.
That is not a man.
Suhammed.
Shame.